today on the matt wall show there's an
opening on the supreme court and it's
been decided that a black woman must
fill it which black woman well any will
do apparently once again we see the
absurd racism of racial equity on full
display also there has been a huge surge
in children experiencing speech delays
because of masking and media matters
publishes a lengthy expose about a
certain bigoted dr phil clip that lots
of people on facebook have seen and
shared and they're very concerned about
that and our daily cancellation will
deal finely with the nft phenomenon is
it a good investment opportunity or is
it the dumbest thing in the history of
the world and a sign of our
civilizations decadence and decay we'll
find out today on the matt wall show
[Applause]
[Music]
well we're all experiencing the hurt at
the gas pump with uh prices being so
high right now but there is there is
help here there is a way around this
there's an incredible app that everyone
who buys gas needs to know about it's
called get upside my listeners are
making up to 25 cents for every gallon
of gas every time they fill up all you
have to do is download the free get
upside app in the app store or google or
google play right now use promo code
walsh and get a bonus 25 cents per
gallon on your first fill up that's up
to 50 cents cash back that you're
getting don't pay full price of the pump
anymore there's no reason to do that get
cash back using get upside just download
the app for free and use promo code
walsh to get up to 50 cents a gallon
cash back on your first tank some people
who drive a lot are making as much as
two to three hundred dollars a month in
cash back and there's no catch you know
the cash gets added right to your
account it's as easy as that you can
cash out any time to your bank account
paypal or an e-gift card for amazon and
other brands just download the free get
upside app and use promo code walsh to
get up to 50 cents a gallon cash back on
your first tank that's code walsh
you know that the democrats are in for
pummeling in the next election when the
elderly liberals on the supreme court
start retiring ahead of time so that
they could be replaced before the next
congress is elected of course in justice
breyer's case it appears that he was
well uh helped in making his retirement
announcement in fact he didn't announce
it at all it simply was announced by the
media that he would be retiring as of
last night he hadn't said a word about
it himself the powers that be seem to be
um dropping a hint and not a very subtle
one either i think when you go to work
and they're throwing a retirement party
for you already and you say well i never
said i was retiring hey congratulations
on your retirement that's a that's a
hint that they want you gone now
assuming that breyer
does as he's told and vacates his seat
that leaves us with the question of who
will replace him
needless to say
we learned during the amy coney barrett
hearing that it is an attack on our
democracy it's an assault on our very
way of life on our sacred institutions
on the norms the blessed norms to
confirm a supreme court nominee during
an election year
he can't do that i even dare say that it
would be an insurrection a tragedy worse
than 15 911s and 12 pearl harbors
and three world war twos
and one world war one that's the
equation if he is replaced before the
election you can't you just can't do it
they were the democrats are very clear
about this
yet it seems that they plan to move
forward with the nomination and
confirmation anyway despite the fact
that doing so will spend the end of
western civilization as they repeatedly
explained when amy coney barrett was
nominated so who will get the nod well
joe biden already announced over a year
ago that whenever he has a spot to fill
on the court he will fill it with a
black woman
which black woman well it doesn't seem
to matter very much
what even is a black woman he can't say
none of them can
but whatever that is and whoever it is
he will find her or him or them
it's quite disappointing really that he
isn't going for a more progressive
choice perhaps you know he could he
could nominate a gender fluid aboriginal
polygamist hawaiian non-binary lesbian
transracial black korean eskimo for the
role we haven't had one of those on the
court in well over a hundred years but
instead biden is is going the safe route
in in in keeping with his promise a
promise that his ring masters have
certainly not forgotten yesterday one
prominent leftist after another came out
to declare that it's it's time for a
black woman on the supreme court the
ringo of the squad ayanna presley uh was
the first out of the gate and she says
it's time for a black woman it's a black
woman's term a turn she says
there's a waiting list organized by
identity and it clearly says that black
women are next in line
but not all black women
some black people don't count as black
people we've learned clarence thomas is
black but his blackness is erased by the
fact that he has the wrong opinions
we need a black woman then who has the
right skin pigment but also the right
thoughts
that's what biden pledged and yesterday
jen pasake renewed that pledge listen
so let's say hypothetically
a supreme court justice
was to retire and announce it on his or
her own terms
does president biden plan to honor his
pledge to nominate a black woman to the
court well i've commented on this
previously the president has uh stated
and reiterated his commitment to
nominating a black woman to the supreme
court and certainly uh stands by that
this is what we call diverse and
inclusive now when entire races and
sexist our sexes are excluded from the
outset
is that even legal
i mean aren't there laws for bidding
government officials or even private
employers from excluding applicants
based on race
you might think so but the law just like
common sense moral decency and all other
considerations must be placed to the
side for the sake of racial equity
not to be confused with racial equality
racial equality promises that all people
will be treated the same regardless of
skin color racial equity promises that
all people will be treated according to
their skin color if the two if the two
concepts seem to be
opposites then well you're catching on
the consequence of this approach is that
whichever black woman is chosen
we won't be able to say that she
achieved anything won't be an
accomplishment
nothing to congratulate her for
we will not be able to say that she was
selected for the job because of her
merits or qualifications she'll be an
affirmative action hire a kind of a
trophy in a display case
the token black woman
it's degrading and dehumanizing even if
the eventual nominee isn't self-aware
enough to feel degraded and dehumanized
by the whole thing
you know jackie robinson
broke the color barrier
and and we say he broke it because he
broke it he smashed it he forced his way
through a system that was stacked
against him because he was such a
phenomenally talented and determined and
courageous man and athlete
he's remembered by history and honored
because of that but if major league
baseball had just said hey we need a
black guy so um you know so that people
don't think we're racist anymore and
then they just pulled the first black
eye off the street that they happen to
stumble across hey you you've got dark
skin come over here and make us seem
less racist
if it didn't work that way then the
story of jackie robinson would be
remembered in quite a different light
and for the worse
of course in this case in modern times
the system is not at all stacked against
black women or black people in general
if you're a racial minority
all of the most powerful institutions in
the country trip over themselves to
celebrate and empower you
laws are written which discriminate not
against you but for you
and that's why it's important to
stipulate that although this racial
equity nonsense degrades and dehumanizes
the alleged victim groups that it
purports to help
and that is an important facet of this
the real victims of this kind of system
are the groups that are specially
excluded
so it's never entirely safe to criticize
racial equity but the safest way to do
it
and the thing that a lot of
conservatives focus on is to point out
how it demeans racial minorities while
claiming to elevate them
you know to say hey you're trying to
help racial minorities it's actually
hurting them
because it is dehumanizing degrading all
that kind of thing
and yeah that we can point that out
that's the safer route the less safe
route
but also the most important point
is that racial equity is explicitly
anti-white it is racist against white
people
and anti-white racism is
evil it's not the first time the buy
administration has announced white males
need not apply
they did the same for covid relief funds
this is their mo
as it's the mo of the left generally
we're watching in real time as explicit
overt racism
and discrimination against an entire
class of people is being normalized
and it's become so normal that even
those of us who recognize it for the
wickedness that it is still probably
don't feel the appropriate amount amount
of outrage when the federal government
announces out loud
you know we don't want white men for
this role
white men can go to hell
there is systemic racism in america
today
and it's against white men
yes they are the victims of it
and we need to keep pointing that out
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
hey by the way if you have not um been
to our
daily wire shop recently um to the um
swag shack
as i call it then you have to go there
dailywire.com shop and just
uh go skim over everything else and go
right to the matt walsh store
and uh i didn't even know i i just
checked it myself for the first time in
a while and there's a bunch of stuff i
didn't even know was on here like for
example you can get a matte wall she can
get a t-shirt which uh lists my
preferred adjectives as i explained with
dr phil handsome and brilliant and if
those are also your preferred adjectives
then you can get a shirt which uh you
know announces that and lets everybody
know so they can refer to you in a way
that validates your lived experience but
we also have these um these are hot off
the presses so we've got these patches
here they're kind of like
uh like sort of like merit badges that
they used to give in the boy scouts but
the boy scouts are effectively dead so
um instead of the boy scouts now we have
the sweet baby gang
and uh you know we got save a boy i
don't know if you could see these in the
camera but the no panda merit badge
return or die you get this one when you
return your shopping cart and uh so
we've got sweet baby game of course you
get the patches
each of these patches cost 77
um
i don't know if that's the exact price
but there's a little bit of a premium
but it's worth it i think
all right let's start with this one of
the um
consequences of masking children as some
of us have been pointing out for years
is that you create
speech delays i mean along with the
psychological uh effects and everything
else
there's speech delays that are a
consequence because children especially
those who already have speech delays
need to see words being formed
in order to know how to say them
and so when when a child goes to speech
therapy this is a very important part of
it the speech therapist is enunciating
the words
and the child is watching the mouth of
the speech therapist
because and that's how they learn
how to how to form those words
themselves
but you put masks on everybody
and that becomes a real problem because
one of the primary tools that children
use
to learn how to speak
which is the visual tool it's not all
audible has been taken away from them
and so there's a local news report
um
wpbf uh abc affiliate and they looked
into this and here's what they found
jacqueline teak says during this
pandemic her speech therapy clinic has
seen an enormous shift in the ages of
their patients before the pandemic only
five percent of patients were babies and
toddlers today it has soared to 20
percent many parents calling it covet
delayed we've seen a 364
increase in patient referrals of babies
and toddlers from pediatricians and
parents and they are children that are
having a difficult time speaking speech
delayed babies start learning how to
speak by reading lips as young as eight
months
so what happens when lips and faces are
covered up by masks all therapists say
for some kids they can work around the
mask and still learn to speak perfectly
fine but for others it can cause speech
delays there's no research out there yet
to say that this could be causing speech
and language delays but most definitely
it's i'm sure a factor it's very
important kids do see your face to learn
so they're watching your mouth that's
orange can you say orange
that was a good try brianna gay is
raising five children but it's her
youngest who needs therapy it definitely
makes a difference when the world you're
growing up in you can't interact with
people and their face
that's super important to
babies so we're seeing a lot of things
that look just like
autism they're not making any
word attempts and not communicating at
all
with their family
okay well so we're just interfering with
our children's ability to speak
how important is that uh who needs to be
able to speak
it's a fundamental human capacity that
we've
interfered with
disabled
uh because of because of the masking
that's another one of the trade-offs
that was made when they when they pushed
the masking stuff and they acted like
there was no trade-off at all better
safe than sorry it's not hurting
anything hurting anything
and she says there there there have been
no studies yet that have confirmed this
and she's right and that has been the
excuse all along that she was not making
excuses but she you know that that
the people who the pro masters this has
been their excuse in their line all
along
when you if you brought up the issue of
speech delays psychological harm all of
this they say well where is your study
show me the show me the study that
proves
beyond a shadow of a doubt that these uh
these consequences will follow from
asking
well there are no studies
you idiot because we've never done
anything like this before in human
history
there's no precedent for it there's
never been an occasion to study it
there's never been a way to study it
we up until this point we had not had
access to a generation of children
who went through their formative years
with their faces covered and everybody
else's faces faces covered
that never existed before so how can we
study it
so without the studies the the the
all-important studies that everybody
demands no matter what claim you make
there's always oh where's the study for
that
you know it is possible to just use your
common damn sense every once in a while
you don't need a study you don't need
something written on a piece of paper uh
research peer-reviewed to confirm what
common sense should tell you
because the only way to get a study
about something like this is to go ahead
and do it
and then afterwards go back and see how
much it harmed the kids that's the only
way to study it
but by the time you're studying it it's
too late the harm is done
the other option is to use your common
sense
and to realize that we're human beings
not like robots
and as human beings um
our ability to see each other face to
face is really important it's a basic
aspect of human existence
if you've ever been around
a child you ever been around a baby
i think of course
a lot of the people the powers that be
they they are they're not around
children at all
a lot of them a bunch of bunch of uh
childless
bitter tyrants
so they might not even know this but if
you've ever been around a baby you'll
you'll notice how what uh it's actually
quite quite incredible how um and i i
often think about this when you see a
baby the way that they kind of
they lock in on your face they know they
don't know much about the world
but um they know to look into your eyes
that's this kind of instinctive thing
even very young babies make eye contact
and you can see them if you're talking
to a baby interacting with a baby you
can see them kind like studying your
face in this very inquisitive way
and when they're studying my face
they're part of what they're thinking is
who is this hairy gross beast
get them away from me but they're also
studying to see oh what's their moving
mouth what does that mean this is what
kids do
um here's a father on the same subject
here a father in loudoun county my
hometown speaking out about this at
school board a school board meeting
apparently the school board meeting is
now in loudoun county they are allowing
people in the room again of course when
i went and spoke at loudoun county they
wouldn't let anybody in the room you had
to line up outside in single file line
and then let you come in for 60 seconds
and then kick you out the door again so
they are allowing people in the room
again very magnanimous of them
and here's the father talking about this
issue with speech delays
my beautiful six-year-old kindergarten
daughter asked to come with me today to
see the people who are forcing her
against her will and mine to wear a mask
mr ziegler right there i have a question
for you do you know her name mr marshall
were you there when she was born mr
hoyler were you there when she got on
the school bus for her first day of
kindergarten mr morris do you know that
she has trouble pronouncing her sp
syllables mr sorokin did you know
wearing a mask is contributing to my
daughter's lcps speech services
of course you don't you don't know any
of this yet you feel that you have the
right to mandate a medical decision from
my child and you feel so strongly about
this that you're willing to break an
executive order to do it and not only
that but you are bullies you're actually
sending students to the office sending
them home and or segregating them for
mass comp non-compliance shame on you
you do not have the right to make
medical decisions for my child this is
my child not yours i want
thank you i want my child to learn to
communicate she needs the option to not
wear a mask during these incredibly
important first years over education
start listening to parents follow eo2
exactly like you followed all of
northamptoes
[Applause]
domestic terrorism at its worst there
so it sounds like they still only give
you 60 seconds
uh you have 60 seconds
all that can be said in 60 seconds and
and that father crammed quite a bit into
his credit
well all his rhetorical questions at the
beginning of course the answer is no do
they know his child do they care about
his child no none of them do
and you send your kid to public school
then
the people determining
what's going to happen to your kid
they're all people who don't know your
kid don't care about them
that's uh that's the reality we said in
public school jordan peterson um
said something important about this he
said that children who can't speak can't
object
i think that's uh quite profound a lot
of profound things jordan peterson says
and that's one of them
perhaps there's perhaps it's not a
coincidence
you know the schools are such big fans
of masking
and it interferes with the child's
ability to communicate
both physically in the moment because
they're literally muffled
and you can't understand what anybody's
saying
that's that's another thing taking
speech delays aside
it can be hard enough with young
children especially if they're not your
child when it's your own child you kind
of understand their language and so my
my two-year-old
will talk and talk to me in her own
version of full sentences and i think
anybody on the outside would have no
clue what she's saying but i know
exactly my wife knows exactly because we
you know we understand her language
because we know her but if it's not your
own child trying to understand you know
a three or four year old
even if they
even if their speech is up to par for
their age group it can already be
difficult
because they're not as
you know they're still learning how to
express themselves
now put a mask on them
that's impossible to understand them
perhaps that's not a coincidence
the school system would prefer it that
way
the kids can't speak can't express
themselves cannot object
can't can't register any protest
the schools have been trying to muffle
kids in various different ways for a
long time
muffle and uh and neuter them in all
kinds of different ways
including through the use of drugs
psychotropic drugs
adhd medication and so on it's just
another way to do that
this is this is ideal like this is the
ideal scenario for the for the
government education system
there's a bunch of kids sitting there
with masks on so these that that's how
they see your kid
this faceless automaton with ears
but but no mouth
can hear what you're saying cannot say
anything back
meanwhile elsewhere in virginia here's a
virginia democrat
taking glenn younkin to task for
praying for him he's quite offended by
that listen
there is a lot going on right now when i
was here about a month ago with freshmen
unexpectedly
the governor the governor elect at the
time he came in this chamber with the
freshmen who were being trained and
taught and talked about how we do things
on the floor and the first things that i
recall him saying was that he he had a
strong prayer life
and that he was praying for everybody
and so far what i've seen from his day
one activities is not someone who is a
man of faith
not a christian
but someone who wants to divide the
commonwealth someone wants that wants to
cause division this is coming with i
know the truth hurts i don't want to
make you cry like saying critical race
theory because i know it hurts your
feelings
so that's something to keep in mind when
you hear people talk about um
unity and how we're going to establish
and
form some sense of unity in our country
can we reach across the aisle can we all
be why can't we all just be friends
again
well keep in mind that video
where as far as that guy is concerned as
a democrat he doesn't even want you
praying for him
your prayers are worthless
i'm sure he claims to be a christian too
but your your prayers are worthless to
him
if he disagrees with you that that's how
much he hates you
that he doesn't even want you to pray
for him
is it possible to have any kind of unity
with people like that i don't see it
when they
when their hatred for you goes down
that deep
where can you go from there
what kind of common ground can you
establish
there's no respect
you know in order to have unity i think
there are a couple of things that you
have to a couple of uh prerequisites one
is that you have to as i always say you
have to you have to unite around
something there's to be some kind of
uniting principle
uh you can't just be unity for the sake
of unity so there's to be some shared
something that you share with the people
that you're
uniting with and then the other thing
that you need
uh some kind of respect there has to be
that's that's one of the things that you
have to share is respect for one another
that's not respect
and it's not just one way i'm not
pretending to be
the uh
the hurt
party here i i would say well i don't
respect him either
so the feeling is mutual
i guess that's what we share we share
our we have a mutual disregard and
disrespect for each other maybe that's
how we can establish our unity
all right let's uh let's just check in
quickly with joe biden um do we have
this clip maybe see if you can make
heads or tails of what he's saying this
is always fun
it's kind of a fun riddle
that's that's one so one good thing that
joe biden provides us with is uh you
know we can always it's kind of a fun
game to try to figure out what the hell
he's even trying to say so
listen to this
but uh
um i might point out you're uh
when i went to dearborn driving that
uh you know uh was up there i don't know
man
it uh
i think the press thought i was crazy i
enjoyed it so much going up and
uh your new ev factory and uh
and that uh that hummer
all right
good good point grandpa thank you go
back to bed now
all right so
media matters are our friends once again
uh they're on the case
they're on my case they're on daily
wires case uh here's the headline and
this is a long can't even read the whole
thing but
um written by arie drenin research
contributions from carly evans so they
got a team of researchers together for
this thing and the headline is on
facebook a dr phil episode about
non-binary identity becomes a bonanza
for right-wing hate
and then it continues
i feel like we need some sad piano music
in the background for this
right-wing figures particularly from the
daily wire weaponized a january 19th dr
phil episode to spread anti-trans hatred
and drive facebook engagement on their
posts
the episode posited non-binary
identities as up for debate and featured
non-binary people and allies alongside
anti-trans parents in the daily wires
matt welsh
media matters examined our data set of
news and politics pages on facebook and
found that among these right-leaning
pages were nearly alone in reacting to
the episode let's stop there for a
second of course of course right
why is that media matters what do you
think
it was a dr phil episode uh it's about a
subject that uh
it obviously interests a lot of people
people on the left especially very
interested in the topic of gender
and yet with this episode as according
to you because you've looked into this
only
or almost only right-wing pages even
acknowledged that it happened
why is that
um right link
right-wing pages were nearly all known
and reacting to the episode driving more
than 3.3 million views to one
selectively edited video
in which walsh mocked the non-binary
panelists repeatedly asked them to
define womanhood that counts as mockery
now i guess just asking a simple
question
asking a question which is really what
do you mean
is mockery when somebody says something
to you and you don't understand what
they mean so you say what do you what do
you mean by that stop mocking me
no i mean maybe i would mock you i mean
it's i wouldn't put it past me to mock
you but first i have to even understand
what the hell you're talking about in
order to mock it
we haven't gotten past square one here
um
and uh and then walsh accused them of
trying to appropriate womanhood and turn
it into basically a costume that can be
worn i did say that
and then they get into they get into the
nitty-gritty here i mean they've really
looked into this they've got bar graphs
and everything here
uh with all of the interactions with
this vid with this video they're very
upset that anybody saw this or
interacted with the video um it says
from january 17th through through 20th
24th right-leaning facebook pages
related to news and politics posted
about the dr phil episode far more often
and earned vastly more total
interactions than either non-aligned or
left-leaning pages
uh and then it gives the actual full
interactions number interaction numbers
and it's all pretty good so this is a
great traffic i'm pretty proud of that
i actually didn't even know that the
video did this well on facebook this is
all good news for me
both shapiro and walsh shared a video
titled leftist traumatized after meeting
me in which walsh mocked the non-binary
guests of the episode for sharing that
they had experienced nightmares and
depression as a result of their
appearance on the show
um
and then it continues from there
and this thing just goes on it goes into
their methodology
using crowd tangle media matters
compiled a list of
1773 facebook pages that frequently
posted about u.s politics from january
1st to august 25th
and uh blah okay
they're very now what's the point of all
this why are they why are they doing all
this
um
well it's not so subtle at all of course
this is them sending a message to
facebook like why hey you're supposed to
censor this you're not supposed to allow
this content out there
it's a it's a scandal according to media
matters that people on facebook were
allowed to see this video
and that tells you everything that you
need to know i mean through all of the
reaction to that dr phil episode
you notice what what what the left has
not done
they have not tried to explain why i'm
wrong i mean
none of them have
there has not been
that i have seen
one single article written
or youtube video posted or even tweet
that says oh you're wrong about what you
said matt and here's why
not even attempting to
because they know they can't explain why
i'm wrong and they also know
here's the real reason why the left is
not in even as media matters says
they're not engaging with this video
they just want it to go away
the real reason is that they know if
they if they try to engage with it
the first thing they're gonna have to do
is define what a woman is
if there's if they allow for if they
engage me in any kind of debate about
this
if they try to address it at all
that's the first question they're gonna
have to answer is what is a woman and
they cannot answer it and they know they
can't
tells you everything you need to know
they're not even trying to claim that
they won the argument they don't want to
have the argument they don't want you to
see it
that's the response to this
that's how you know you're really
on the right path
when you say something that's uh
they're not even gonna kind of try to
try to shout you down they just
they don't want anyone to hear that you
said it
all right this is interesting and i've
seen a number of headlines about this
this one in the wall street journal
by ellen gamerman is the author and the
headline is bradley cooper benedict
cumberbatch and the golden age of nude
men
if you want to hear more about this
subject i'll read a little bit for you
it says mail and there's a point that
i'm gonna make and we'll get to it a
second um
there's a point you know
so to speak
male full frontal nudity once the stuff
of art house films is going mainstream
bradley cooper benedict cumberbatch are
trouser-free and oscar contenders and
sebastian stan bears it all in a coming
hulu mini-series the sight of naked male
stars can shock in ways that female
nudity no longer does making for the
kind of edginess that uh
that hollywood loves and then it goes
apparently this is a big trend now
there's a lot of different movies where
the men are showing off their penises
and then it says
full frontal the full frontal man
reflects several forces overtaking
hollywood right now he represents a
cosmic rebalancing of the scales as the
entertainment industry attempts to
address sexism
he's an argument that streaming
platforms largely free from ratings
rules can play to male and female
audiences with new abandon and he's a
path to free publicity with the
potential to light up social media has
happened with mr cooper's comments about
his nude bathtub scene in the film
nightmare alley went viral okay so this
is what's interesting or at least
informative um
you know
the article talks about how this
balances the scales
of sexism and addresses the legacy of
sexism that's much of what they are
that's much of the what the article
focuses on
by having men get naked also
so
you know at the beginning of the metoo
movement
we heard a lot of complaints
um about
in fact often very quite valid
complaints about how women are
objectified by hollywood
um and how their bodies are treated with
you know like tools without treated
without any respect
um
totally valid complaints
so then how does
how is hollywood addressing this
complaint about the objectification of
women
have they decided to stop objectifying
women
no instead the way to balance it out is
just to objectify men also
and the a lot of the critics and media
and so forth they're happy with that
that's a solution they're happy with
which only proves that they never had a
problem with objectification per se
that was never really their issue
their problem is just that it wasn't
happening to both parties
so they don't really have a problem with
one group being mistreated it's just
that if they're mistreated they want
everyone to be mistreated in the same
way
they want everyone to be to be
mistreated equally nothing wrong with
degrading people and dehumanizing them
just do it to everybody
it's no surprise that this is the
solution because in order to really
launch any sort of critique
of the objectification of
the female body or of the male body
in order to actually criticize that
you have to start talking about things
like
dignity
you know the dignity of the human person
the value of the human person
and that's a conversation that
they don't want to have on the left and
they really can't have they don't have
the language for that
they don't have the philosophical kind
of foundation for that
so this is the solution
uh you don't like it when women have to
take their clothes off
well i've just had the men take their
clothes off too problem solved
all right let's get now to the comment
section
[Music]
you want to leave a video comment submit
a video call me go to dailywire.com
sweetbabycomments and uh let's check out
our first one
hola
papa walsh i like many other spg fans
are very grateful for the 55 minutes of
inspired wisdom and counsel we received
from our pre-ordained cult leader
and we understand after the show you're
probably busy
pushing shopping carts sledding or
planning the next panda assassination
but when are we going to get a matt
walsh bonus hour spg for life
a matt walsh bonus hour
so like doing the show i don't even know
what you mean by that doing the show
again
or that you know what that is that's
more that's more work for me
so
why do you think i do this for a living
because i don't want to have to work
hard so
now you're trying to put more on my
plate
tempted to ban you from the show for
that
uh all right let's let's watch the next
one
matt good evening uh
watching watching tonight's or today's
show i watch it at night uh
i i literally
i literally did a spit take i was
drinking a sip of beer watching your
show
and uh peter dinklage
says and i quote
have i not done enough from my soapbox
perhaps i'm not loud enough now
this might be just me uh but my first
thought was uh well
maybe
two soap boxes stacked on
that's number one and number two
uh i i don't think it's the volume of
your voice i i don't think it's that
people perhaps maybe can't hear you
um
maybe maybe maybe they can't see you
over the podium
sgb
how dare you i
how did how did that video make it
through i'm i'm offended by it
it's not something to joke about
peter dinklage is a great test be a
great actor
and you know jokes like that they really
sell them short i think
how dare you sir
let's go to some of the written comments
this is from
energyjtw says my co-worker a
55-year-old shaved head welder with a
large truck went on a date yesterday and
told me about it she immediately asked
about his opinion of trump and cursed
him ruining the date when he said he's a
nut but had good policy she said lord
where can i find a good older liberal
man his response focus on the men in a
prius with a man bun then paid the bill
and left early uh my only problem with
that is that he paid the bill because
she's she's a apparently is a feminist
liberal woman and so
she should want to she don't need no man
and she should want to pay the bill
herself really and pay your half of it
as well to show how empowered she is
so i would have paid without i would
have left without paying the bill at all
even my portion of it for her own sake
to respect her as a as a good liberal
feminist woman uh but other than that
it's it's right that's the right move of
course and this is also why people say
that uh you know on a first date
don't talk about things like politics
and religion they also say that just in
general this is not polite conversation
to talk to people about and you have to
really know someone well i guess before
you discuss those things i i very much
disagree with that because first of all
i mean the worst thing that can happen
on a on a date on a first date is that
there's nothing to talk about right well
and you're sitting there staring at the
other person there's nothing to say
that's the most awkward thing
um and the problem is that if you rule
out politics religion those sorts of
topics what else is there to talk about
you've taken
the best
fodder for conversation you've taken it
out of the equation
the table so speaking now what are you
going to do now you're just going to sit
there staring at you i don't i don't
know what else to talk about other than
these kinds of things
and the other advantage is when you i i
think should be one of the first things
you bring up
are uh these kinds of issues because
it's going to tell you what you
it's going to tell you about this
person's values
it's going to tell you whether you could
stand to be in this room with the other
in a room with the other person for an
extended period of time which is good
information to have i think
um
let's see
tina says matt's dating advice has
seriously saved my love life i finally
found a masculine conservative man who
believes in a marriage and family as
much as i do i'd be single for the rest
of my life if it weren't for the love
gurus or the daily wire love gurus i
like that
that's another
i'll add that to my preferred adjectives
i suppose
um
maximilian m k gill says a good rule of
thumb is not to apologize to anyone
unless you have made a mistake
right but even then
you're apologizing to that person
specifically and not in front of an
audience
so i'm accused sometimes of being
anti-apology in general where i'm
sitting here saying never apologize to
anyone of course you apologize to people
if you wrong them in some way
but
you apologize to the wronged party
personally
not in front of the entire world
um sue says ben shapiro's dating advice
go to church and you'll find someone
with your own values
uh and several comments along those
lines as we've talked about dating and
marriage over the last few days and that
is good advice i mean that's if you want
to find someone in real life who shares
your values good place to start is
church one of the problems though is and
it might this depends a lot on where you
live and what kind of church you go to
but um sadly
a lot of the churches these days
especially post covid when all the
churches shut down and then they opened
up again and said you know because they
shut down for a year or whatever or
several months depending on where you
live and they said oh you don't really
need us that much so we're going to shut
down then they opened up again and said
never mind you do need us
and a lot of people in the interim said
well if you think we don't need you
we're not coming back and so um there
are even fewer people at church now
sadly
and um
so that is going to
you know the fewer fish in that in that
particular sea and then also at many
churches
um
the uh the age range of the average
congregant is quite a bit older than the
average single person
that's that's a big problem for single
people and for the church
um
let's see one more
b.o kiddo says
um dating is awesome right now all the
sex you want and something better and
younger is just around the corner but
people are getting married and they
divorce it's almost like marriage is
unnatural perhaps instead of pushing
people to something that is a negative
experience for everybody involved
we should just get rid of marriage
who are you trying to fool who are you
trying to convince i think you're trying
to convince yourself
this is awesome i never i never form any
meaningful bond with any human being
i just move on to the next one
there's always something a thing
notice how you say not some one younger
even but something
treating people like things never
forming any real bonds never having any
real commitment never having the the
lasting companionship of a of a of a
woman who i really love and respect it's
wonderful i love it no you don't
stop pretending
you don't
because no human can
because i i assume you are a human being
right typing this to me
there are basic human needs that that we
all have
it's like if you were starving to death
in the desert and you tried to convince
me that us is great who needs food
well you do you need it
um
and food is a basic human need water
shelter
uh companionship
love these are actual human needs
and you cannot have a real fulfilling
human life without them you cannot have
joy without them you just can't doesn't
exist
it's like a mathematical impossibility
so that's how i know
that you are
you were you were crying over your
keyboard as you type that you are the
literal manifestation of that meme with
the person with the with the happy mask
and they're crying behind it that's you
and also this this whole thing about oh
marriage is unnatural that's why people
get divorced
um
just because you suck at it right just
because you're too weak to do it
just because you're too much of a weak
nothing of a man to remain loyal to a
woman
and to care for a family
you know just because you're not a real
man don't put that on the rest of us
there there have been throughout human
history like literally billions of
marriages that have worked
and just because you can't do it doesn't
mean the rest of us can't
but thanks for watching the show
the latest episode of adam corolla's
comedy series truth yeller is streaming
right now adam is joined by silicon
valley actor and comedian tj miller who
wears a very short clip on tie and takes
no prisoners check it out ladies and
gentlemen comedian actor and friend tj
miller
[Applause]
oh my gosh hello
sorry i was i was just jogging i was
trying to find my dog
but i double fisted because you know it
evens out as you jog the weight this guy
looked at me and he goes it's true it is
true
i'm joking but you're serious this guy
really does
do it hi hey thank you for having me
thanks for coming out oh i'm excited
this is just a prop though do you want
this
oh you won't take it huh why coven you
one of those guys huh
won't drink a stranger's beer because
the coven
so head to dailywire.com subscribe and
use code miller for 25 off your
membership look out for the new episode
with tj miller right now also the daily
wire is making it easier to listen to
all of our content on the go with with
the launch of our new uh function which
is called listen appropriately so which
means you'll now be able to listen to
all of your favorite daily wire content
on the website and the dw app listen is
here to make soaking up our content as
convenient as possible with a limited ad
audio experience whether it's catching
morning water with a morning cup of
coffee taking in the latest hot takes
from your favorite host or exploring our
growing radio theater you'll get all of
the content that you love and if you get
interrupted no worries you can pick up
right where you left off with continue
listening and that's not all we've made
sure that it's available to members and
non-members so get ready to listen
because we've got a lot to say
and finally and most importantly
as the beloved author of the
best-selling children's lgbtq plus book
johnny the walrus i am now a very
important voice in the transgender
conversation that's why i was invited to
dr phil to discuss these most important
issues with experts who could uh not
even tell me what a woman was if you saw
the video if you haven't seen it yet i
highly recommend you check it out and
even more importantly if you haven't
picked up a copy of my best-selling lgbt
children's book you should do so
immediately it's sold out in the first
48 hours when it was released but don't
worry more copies are on the way reserve
your copy of johnny the walrus now on
amazon now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
good news paris hilton is back on the
scene she reemerges in fact at the same
time as lena dunham two people who are
much closer in iq than they are in
physical appearance with these two
grabbing headlines and all we need is
amy schumer to come out out of hiding
and the three most annoying women of the
last 25 years will be sharing the
spotlight at the same time
the fourth horse of the apocalypse will
finally be upon us so we can get on with
armageddon already but hilton is not
focused on her past she is very much a
woman of the present and of the future
so she appeared on the tonight show this
week to promote whatever the hell she's
promoting and also to have a
conversation that our ancestors would
have found utterly impenetrable and
mystifying even most people alive on
earth today will probably have that
reaction
listen to hilton and fallon discuss nfts
i jumped in i know i heard i'm so happy
i taught you what they were you did you
taught me what's up and then i bought an
ape i got an ape too because i saw you
on the show with people and you said you
got a moonpay so i went and i copied you
and did the same thing you did mm-hmm
this is your this is your ape
it's really cool
like the hat the shades
and what how did you pick because
because you can pick your your your ape
yes i was going through a lot of them
and i was like i want something that
like kind of reminds me of me
but like
this one it's it does i think we we made
like another version of it where he
takes the hat off and blonde hair comes
out
yeah cause you could do whatever you
want mm-hmm animated version we're part
of the same people we're part of the
same community we're both apes i love it
uh here's my this is my yours
yours is so cool i love the red heart
sunglasses i love the captain hat it
reminded me of me a little bit because i
wear striped shirts
i've worn these heart sunglasses because
my daughters
just as a joke they have them and as a
joke i put them on so i've done this and
i love yacht rock and to being breezy so
i'm like yeah
that kind of and i like the blue mm-hmm
dude look at this they look like they
could be friends they're buddies
yeah i can't quite explain it but
something about that 77 second clip
sends me spiraling into despair
and paris hilton has always had that
effect on me honestly but this is
something even worse
as you can see in the clip they're
showing off their nfts which are digital
images of cartoon monkeys and hats
and they both spent hundreds of
thousands of dollars on them
not even for the card that fallon is
showing off but for the digital
representation of those cards
the audience of course is perplexed and
doesn't know how to react
should we applaud the two millionaires
who paid for a monkey picture that cost
more than my house should we laugh
let's do both that seems safest let's
laugh and applaud the obscene decadence
and emptiness of our culture
for those who are still perhaps confused
about nfts all you have to know is that
they are as stupid as they seem they are
what you thought they were to paraphrase
dennis green may he rest in peace
your confusion probably stems from your
assumption that there must be more to
this fad there must be something you're
missing there's no way that it's as
idiotic as it appears to be i mean it
looks like people are spending thousands
of dollars buying digital pet rocks that
have absolutely no inherent worth use or
purpose and whose monetary value is
based entirely on a sort of collective
mania
that can't really be it you think
but no you were right the first time it
is that these are like beanie babies or
pez dispensers but worse because adults
are collecting them and also the things
don't even exist
the pez dispenser at least dispenses pez
what does the monkey picture do
you can sit and stare at it and reflect
on the meaninglessness of your life but
that's about the only function they
serve
nfts are artificial
their value is artificial now some nft
apologists will say that the same is
true of physical art i mean what's the
difference between owning a digital
representation of a cartoon monkey in a
hat
and owning say the mona lisa
well first of all you're a [ __ ]
second the mona lisa is a physical
painting a physical object created by
the hand of an all-time master and it
exists in the physical world where there
is just the one
it has 500 years of history it took
years to make it's not a digital
phantasm which is not only ugly and dumb
looking but which can be obtained by
millions of people all at once
all you need to do is take a screenshot
of the monkey and you own it as much as
paris hilton does i took a screenshot of
that
and now i have it too it's mine now
i'm the nft owner now paris hilton
you may not have the original code or
whatever that's what the nft oh is the
original code and that's what makes who
cares
it's exactly the same thing
there's no inherent difference between
your screenshot and her original
this by the way is a problem that nft
merchants have run into a few months ago
the guy who made that youtube video 10
years ago called annoying orange which
features an orange talking and being
annoying
tried to sell the original video quote
unquote as an nft but then a bunch of
people on the internet simply stole it
because anything can be stolen on the
internet with ease
and the plan fell apart and so now he
just instead released it again he
re-released the youtube video on youtube
again
now you might say that physical money is
also artificial in the sense that it's
produced and its value is in many ways
subjective you're on perhaps more solid
ground with that comparison but the
problem is that nfts take all of the
worst aspects of artificial fiat
currency and amplify them
it seems to issue a challenge to
physical cash saying oh you think you're
inherently worthless and artificial well
check this out
nfts are the worst kind of fiat currency
you know we call it fiat currency
traditionally because the value of your
twenty bill comes from the government's
fiat it's declaration
that the thing is worth exactly that
amount
now there are significant problems with
that system but it's not as bad as the
monkey cartoon which has value based on
paris hilton's fiat rich stupid people
have declared that it has value and it
will it will retain that value as long
as the rich stupid people remain
interested and as long as enough
non-rich stupid people continue to care
not exactly the basis for a stable
monetary system
yet this all makes sense in a certain
way
because we live in an artificial age
um artificiality is our calling card it
is the hallmark of our culture and there
is nothing more artificial than an nft
well for now anyway
as we've discussed on this show before
the next horizon is horizon which is
what facebook is calling the metaverse
and that is the virtual reality world
where according to mark zuckerberg's
vision you can abandon your flesh and
blood existence entirely and immerse
yourself in cyberspace
this week a commercial for facebook's
metaverse went viral though the ad is
actually from a year or two ago
what you should know is is that the
actual metaverse as it currently exists
looks worse than it does in this old
advertisement
so this is the metaverse at its
theoretical best
and it's still a nightmare watch
beyond our world
there's another world
and it's right here
on my face
welcome this is horizon think of me as
your guide self-appointed spokes avatar
here to show you around you know horizon
is filled with possibilities he can play
stuff make stuff fly stuff whoa really
love the stash stuart
what up stuart wait i want a mustache
horizon isn't about rules or limits or
pants
or people telling you not to fly an
airplane while drinking your fresh
ground fair trade french press morning
coffee through a curly straw isn't that
right debbie
so there it is i i love in even in the
ad uh how the women who are you know in
the metaverse they're they're with their
husbands at home
and totally ignoring
their family so they can have this dumb
thing on their face
so if you want to block out your
immediate physical environment and
everybody in it so that you can inhabit
the floating severed husk of a nick jr
cartoon character and interact with
other disembodied beings in a sterile
and artificial environment constructed
by big tech oligarchs and designed to
give them direct access to your brain
then boy are you in luck
i just never realized that our dystopia
would look so much like paw patrol
what's the point of the metaverse what
are you supposed to do in it well
zuckerberg says that you can you can
have virtual meetings
so if you want to experience all of the
worst aspects of zoom conference calls
and in-person meetings with none of the
benefits of any of them then this is
your solution you can also shop in the
metaverse we've looked at walmart you
know walmart is now constructing stores
in virtual reality so you can flee from
the confines of your mortal frame and
experience the unfettered joy of
retail shopping
there's so many things you can do with
metaverse the hope is that eventually
you'll do everything in the meadows it
will be like the matrix but a lot less
cool
now you might think that this will never
take off you know it looks so bland and
dismal and pointless there's just no way
any significant number of people will
ever choose to involve themselves in it
and you might be right i hope you're
right but consider that our ancestors if
you had asked them
would have declared with confidence that
nobody in the future would ever choose
to sit around on their butts for 13
hours a day staring at images on screens
and yet here we all are
if you had shown them a cell phone and
told them that in the not-too-distant
future people would spend the majority
of their days simply staring at it
that they would even stare at it when
they're around other people that they
would ignore their children and their
spouses to stare at it that they would
ignore that the flesh and blood humans
in favor of the screen
that they would be so committed to
staring at it that they would kill
themselves because they can't stop
staring at it when they drive their cars
that people would literally be walking
into walls and off of cliffs because
they can't take their eyes off the damn
screen if you had told them all that
they would not have believed you
they would not have seen what could
possibly be so appealing about the
screen that it would compel us to
forsake our physical existence for it
most of us though we lived this way
still can't explain what's so appealing
about it i have a theory
and it's why i believe the metaverse
will very much become a thing and soon
it will become the thing the only thing
the reason is that the purpose of all of
this artificiality in modern life
is to numb us to the realities of human
existence
because out in the world in life
there is joy and fear and pain and
suffering and love and hate and death
and that's too much for the modern man
that last thing death you know is
especially too much for him as his
reaction to covid clearly demonstrated
so he buries his head in his screen
it becomes like some kind of existential
anesthesia
this is why people flee into the
metaverse because
it allows them a final escape from any
semblance of authentic human existence
so soon we'll all be fake like paris
hilton
with her 200 thousand dollar monkey
picture
another cheerful thought to ponder and
that is why nfts and the metaverse and
paris hilton
are all today canceled
and that'll do it for us today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day
[Music]
the godspeed wall show is produced by
sean hampton executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover our technical director is
austin stevens production manager pavo
vadowsky the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters matt wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 22.
john bickley here daley wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our
show morning wire on today's episode
supreme court justice stephen breyer is
set to retire human rights organizations
condemn harsh coveted policies and the
supreme court takes on affirmative
action
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire